and then of course last of all we've got
uh ip man
what can you say yeah what's the the
best one of the best if not the best
martial arts movie especially in the
past yeah i can agree with that yeah
there's a lot of i mean you know i'm
sure a lot of people who are
massive martial arts buff would argue
there's a lot of the earlier films like
some of the jetty's early stuff some of
jackie chan's earlier stuff
this happened to gently he just kind of
disappeared she's kind of
jetted so far as far as i know
as far as the [ __ ] out so as far as i
know what happened with jetley is that
after
fearless which was the 2008 yeah which i
thought was a [ __ ] amazing like he's
supposed to be his last
that was supposed to be his last like
epic right um martial arts film
and uh it was kind of well received it
was it was
it's like a very seven six out of ten
film all right
i thought it was really good i was it
was actually like i think it's really
underrated for a gentleman
i mean his his older stuff is just way
better yeah i know i know but in terms
of modern stuff
you know and that was supposed to be his
last one and then what ended up
happening was is that the expendables
were like money
um so that was actually like so that was
like that was like his last action film
and since then he kind of said that as
far as i know he kind of quit doing
uh big uh big martial arts films yeah
cause i think it's just too intense
like it's a lot because you've done
those things scenes like choreography is
like
insane i just i just remember the
[ __ ] expendables movie like yeah
i was like talk about the most like
wanker-ish movie
like let's just get as many big people
as possible
it's fun right that was all right
but have you seen uh this donut i've
seen i've seen him you have what did you
watch
man i actually watched it not too long
ago because you recommend
you like it yeah it's really [ __ ]
good i mean i love gently it's got one
of my favorite fight scenes is when he
uh
the the fighting the japanese and the
karate
like ten of them and he's like back to
that scene i think it's like the best
one of the best [ __ ] martial arts
scenes of all time i'm
talking about clips you can re-watch on
youtube i've re-watched that yeah
okay to be fair all right yeah that's
fair enough you can watch kung fu fights
but like you can't watch that scene but
no kind of oh man it's out of context
it's so good it's just like so the story
of it man is uh it's about when uh japan
is invading uh china
um way back and then i think there's a
there's a scene where
uh but once they've invaded they're like
oh well you know japanese karate or
something is the
superior so bring your bring your
chinese uh people to practice with
yeah that's literally what it is like if
you win you get a bag of rice or
something
yeah and he's like i'll take on ten of
you and okay it's kind of cheesy but it
is epic but it's so [ __ ] epic and he
like snaps their legs doing it it's
insane i feel that
i feel that that kind of cheesiness
though in martial arts films is what
makes a martial art yeah it totally is i
feel like
it set that scene alone it set the
stakes perfectly
where it's just like oh [ __ ] i'm ready
to see him [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah
and he just takes on 10 black belts
that's not even like the end of the film
though i think i'm halfway through yeah
but that's it's but it's the best fight
it's the best fight of the franchise
right because i remember when uh because
the previous guy he fought like three
black belts and he's like [ __ ] i'll take
on all of you and it's just
it's just one of the few moments in film
where you're just like
i'm ready for this man i i know this
would never happen
yeah i i don't care how cheesy this is
especially like when you're like
uh would you so when i was like 16 when
i was watching all these movies i just i
legitimately thought like martial arts
like badass and i'm like dude this is
epic
but obviously now with all the you know
the mma fighters that like fought them
and
yeah now it's not so epic because you're
like okay the mma fighters should kill
these guys
but when you're like 16 you think like
oh [ __ ] this is like the superior way of
fighting yeah yeah
like this is epic oh my god like it's
it's so cool
you strengthen your speed and now yeah
it's so [ __ ] cool right
but yeah back then you're like oh my god
this is amazing yeah yeah
there's a lot of martial like uh gently
uh gently's earlier staff is amazing
obviously
jackie chan's earlier cinema
cinemagraphy is amazing as well yeah
love like drunken master and stuff like
that yeah such a good film
um what are some really good what's that
i forgot what jetley's high straight
film is called it's this 1980s film
it's really highly rated uh is it fisted
the dragon is it or enter the end of the
dragon or something and so the dragon's
the bruce lee with no no sorry it's
the legend that's like his his like i
think it has like 100 percent of rotten
tomatoes yeah i say fist of fury but i'm
pretty sure it's bruce lee that's pissed
with jet li is a really good one but
yeah that's
it depends if you like martial arts film
where they use like wires like some
people don't like it when they do that
uh it's kind of like waifu right yeah
yeah i kind of prefer it when they're
just like beating the shirt
i don't i know it has a name it's like a
firework why why why
wow it's it's it's not really martial
arts but it is martial arts
really good 2006. i really liked hiro
which had uh donnie yen in it as well
yeah anjali the story's so [ __ ] cool
yeah i i think that story
i feel like i haven't really sat down
and watched like a lot of jet league
films
his stuff is actually like really
[ __ ] good because
uh doesn't have oh another one i think
it's called uh
it might be called war or like warrior
or something it's like uh it's about
like the
three kingdoms or something in china way
back oh
yeah like sangokshi warrior yeah what is
it called i think it's called warrior
might be called
just warrior and it's such a good fight
yeah gently's the main character and uh
it's like this um
about how like a general uh got like i
don't want to spoil it but
you should watch it it's really fun
really really [ __ ] good and i feel
like
um because i i didn't want to put
another martial arts film on uh
my my three by three but i feel like one
of the few things southeast asians can
be proud about
are our [ __ ] martial arts films
because you know like the raid
yeah anger is really yeah yeah pretty
pretty much the only thing of thai
culture that's ever been like
popularized outside um but yeah like i
like i was you know really happy to see
like the the royal ladies
martial art films you know you think of
like you know ip man it's more like very
clean
the raids are really [ __ ] good raids
indonesian right yeah it's indonesia but
directed by a welsh guy
oh really it's a wash guy who directs oh
[ __ ] right yeah is that is that the raid
one or raid two i think
because i know you're invited to raid
two raid who directed raid one and two
can you check real quick i swear
that's another thing i've heard of that
i've never seen the raid
the raid one it's like such a yeah yeah
just get to the top of an apartment
building
yeah that's it it's it's it's basically
just a fighting game
yeah it's basically just like double
dragon yeah it's just double dragon
just the fighting's like the
choreography is insane
yeah gareth evans yeah the most welsh
name on it
literally two welsh names got off the
name fair enough
it's like it's so bizarre there's a
welsh guy directing an indonesian film
oh yeah i do but it's just like awesome
like it's such a good fight
some cross-cultural pollination yeah
look at us here too
but yeah i mean i yeah i [ __ ] love
fighting uh martial arts movies
yeah i've watched nearly all of jetly's
films i think i've watched most of them
i couldn't watch some of the older ones
because they were impossible to find
online
right um and i've watched i think all of
donnie yen's films pre-ipaman
i haven't watched it man four i heard it
was okay i've really liked it band four
really
yeah i actually it's my second favorite
maybe i'll watch it tonight
because uh because i feel like ip-man
four is just three was the worst
yeah i feel like if man four was just it
man two
done better yeah because my problem with
ip man two is that
the villain is just so comical that i
just couldn't take him seriously
let's characterize his character so the
whole selling point to like a western
audience of uh ipman was just that
it's the guy who trained bruce lee yeah
that's literally the selling point of
that yeah
fair enough but he i th he's supposed to
be like a master or something yeah i
don't know
i i mean that is a cool like catch to be
honest i mean that's how it was marketed
and
and the story i again i don't know how
how true it is uh but it's an
interesting
made-up story maybe if it is i don't
know if it's real or not
it's true it's a real character but the
events are fictional yeah
that's normally how it goes yeah with
martial arts people it's kind of hard to
survive some of the [ __ ] yeah
i mean like i'm sure they fought all
those people but they probably died
halfway through yeah i mean i don't i
don't think you did fight 10 black belts
no no that's uh that's yeah probably uh
probably
dramatized unless he's like a [ __ ]
super saiyan but yeah there's another
donnie yen film that's actually really
good where he's like a detective in a
small town
uh i think in a village and
it's really good because it's like a
mystery of the martial arts and it's
just yeah it's really good i've got what
it's called again i've watched these
movies so long ago yeah
it came after it man same with jackie
chan as well some of his
best works are when he was young like
[ __ ] police story
is fantastic is that the scene where he
jumps on the wire yeah
yeah yeah it is completely real what's
it called what do you think about
flashpoint
might be flashpoint yeah i think it's
what's the post is it yellow the poster
the yellow one is oh
again i might have remembered it
incorrectly because it's been someone
watching big brother i have to go back
to the thing and watch it i might be
misremembering i feel like one
underrated donnie yen film is i think
it's
spx or something like that what's he
what's the plot
i i honestly i do not remember but i
the only reason sps just sounds like a
law firm let me let me because what
happened was that all right you're jack
you're bruce lee
but you had jackie chan and then when
jackie chan was getting older jet li was
making films
yeah and then when jetley was getting
all that donnie yen came in but i don't
really know who it is now
who's like the main martial arts guy who
is the main like face of martial arts i
don't even know
like yeah
i think it still is done again because
he's in the the new marvel film
yeah but they also don't really utilize
him much i mean he's the i mean he's the
villain isn't it i feel like i feel just
like monsters
films of kind of just like a little bit
of a dying breed almost in like
especially in the west i feel like i'm
sure like you know if you go to asia and
southeast asia they're still making well
i mean
the past well the past like 20 years
have all been from china like
right it manages from uh china right um
and then donnie yen is in rogue one uh
from star wars but
again i when i was watching that movie
and you can see what donnie yen does
yeah you're kind of disappointed because
you're like donnie ann is such a
it was so [ __ ] good and they barely
use him he just swings a [ __ ]
thing around yeah
yeah a lot of people could have done
what donaian did in that film and i feel
like
why if you're getting donnie yen and he
did he doesn't really speak much in the
film right
because he i don't think he can speak
much english so all i'm saying is there
hasn't been a rush hour or two yet
there hasn't been a modern rush hour
with johnny yeah yeah honestly
[ __ ] yeah and i i i i ice cube
my stupid donny
[Music]
movie industry we just gave you a
million dollar idea donnie in an ice
cube
in rush hour seven or whatever the next
one is
oh my god i'm thinking about what's spl
spl what that's the plot of that movie
can you tell me the plot
spl well um
[Music]
yeah but i remember there's one fight
scene in spl in sbl which is like
completely just
improvised i feel like yeah okay is that
in the street yeah it's in the street
and it's such a [ __ ] good fight scene
and then because
the the whole premise around this uh the
whole background around this fight scene
is that they train together these two
uh these two actors uh donnie yen and
i'm not sure what the other person is
but they train together and because they
were so familiar with each other's
fighting style they literally just
improvised this fight scene with just so
cool with just this basic okay here's
what's meant to happen
but let's just try to kill each other
and then let's just get it on film
yeah that's so cool it's such a good
film as well it prepares a police
detective who's suffering from cancer
and about to retire resorts to illegal
means in order to capture ruthless
tribes
all i remember was there was a police
detective in it i'm just like
that's that's like it's it's either like
traditional like historical setting or
there are police
um but i mean yeah like oh god how do
you like describe this three by three
it's like how did you describe any how
did you describe any three by three
you could describe mine pretentious film
creatures yeah pretentious pretentious
guilty pleasure something with wood with
p
yeah p yp because
uh
um but yeah i guess those are our three
by threes i hope you uh get to watch
some interesting movies if you haven't
seen some of these
uh yeah please go and watch all the
movies i have some movie recommendations
that i will be watching i guess now
yeah i've honestly come out with this
with some movie recommendations and this
was actually
obviously i i always always got time we
know what we're doing after this
sit down baby but no i mean like i it
feels good to be able to talk about
movies because i feel like i don't get
to talk about movies a lot even though
like
i've i kind of realized whenever i talk
about movies i've seen a lot of movies
and i feel like you guys have seen a lot
of movies as well and we
even like off camera we don't really
talk about movies
in general i think i think it just has
to do with the fact that we haven't
really
had time to just sit down and watch
something i've not watched movies in a
while yeah me neil
it's gotten i feel like i don't know i
feel like people don't watch
as many movies anymore yeah yeah if it's
not on netflix then i probably haven't
seen it but i'd say i watched like
90 of the films i've seen in like
between the ages
of like um 18
and 14. yeah i think i think that's
usually like
the period life i'm gonna watch a lot of
movies also when i discovered you could
just google the movies and i was like
holy [ __ ]
yeah i mean my dad used to collect like
a shitload of dvds like blockbuster was
still a thing so like i just watched a
lot of the movies with my dad
yeah i mean i i watch a lot less movies
than i do
than i did before as well because now
it's just all been replaced by anime
right and uh a lot of anime movies
and youtube as well yeah but if you're
on youtube but i feel like if there's a
big enough movie then i probably
have seen it like i'm i'm surprised no
one put any marvel movies here
uh who's [ __ ] cares about marvel i mean
i care about marvel i i'm just like
marvel's that one franchise where i'm
just like hello i'm a normal
yeah it's fun but it's not like i never
like i'm never like [ __ ]
dude that made me think something that
made me like yeah it's like if i'm gonna
watch it if i'm gonna watch this i know
i was like
really [ __ ] invested in infinity ward
end game
i'll say that i didn't i didn't even
watch those end game was good but
again it wasn't like i thought it was
amazing but it wasn't like something
that made me like when i left
the cinema like a week later i don't
think about endgame
well so i'm surprised no one put john
wick as well because i i thought i was
close
someone was going to put john wick on
john was just another one of those like
it's fun turn your brains no no
no no no no no no no i'm not saying it's
a bad movie yeah john wick is probably
like my favorite action series it's it's
like in in the west
they have uh john wick and in the east
they have it man that's that's like
ip-man is just like the uh asian
equivalent of john wick
dude man i just i'm not man i think so i
i it's
holds a very dear place in my heart when
i except i've watched all the john wick
movies in cinema
yeah and like i've watched the last one
that came out alone and it was the
cinema was
empty and i had like such an amazing
time watching that it was like the last
bro it was just fun i got to put my legs
up on the chair in front of me i had all
my popcorn and i just got to enjoy it
bro
so good it was such a good dude i'm so
excited for the next one
i've only seen the first john wick movie
sorry i'm so hyped for that so you have
to
i know i i don't know better yeah the
second one's amazing
again it's like it's it's one it's
another one of those like long list of
movies that i hear people talking about
saying it's amazing and i'm like all
right i'll watch it i don't want to be
too normal
i didn't put it on but it's yeah because
sometimes i just don't know what movies
to watch because i i didn't like it's
weird now because i don't know where to
start because
you know we're so engrained in like
anime culture that i know you know when
there's a hot anime coming out but in
terms of movie recommendations
anything from like the past five years
if it's not been a lot talked about a
lot then i just probably have that's
true i mean i barely have enough time to
watch anime little and
[ __ ] movies joey you don't watch
anime period no i don't
i don't watch movies anime this is how
it goes